[Music]
how many of you guys
like to spend your days at the hospital
oh yeah hell yeah and i used to get paid
a fun place right
when i was getting paid i like that's
true i would like to spend if i was
getting paid to be at the hospital i'd
definitely i haven't been recently like
during covet times because i heard it's
crazy in there now but pre-culvert it
seemed pretty fun
my favorite thing was the hospital
cafeteria
ugh we have to go to a good one yeah
next level dude what was fun about the
hospital and what was great about the
cafeteria
so i like the hospital because it's like
super chill and they got the dopest
adjustable beds
and then they have like a patient yeah a
tv
yeah true because which experience are
you talking about being a patient or a
visitor
or a patient and then like even
everyone's friendly like most nurses are
pretty friendly
so it's just a friendly environment you
got like these adjustable things
and every room is a suite like it has a
bathroom in there
it's just it's like spa living kind of
yeah you're almost dying
yeah what no i'm not down i was almost
dying from pneumonia
and shivering and they're like nope he
can't have any blankets because he needs
to
keep his temperature down and my mom's
like but he's cold
and i'm like [ __ ] i better get
some good popsicles from this [ __ ]
[ __ ] i like how you're cold but you want
ice cream yeah well because you always
get popsicles or something when you're a
kid you know so then like
yeah and then later you start to eat
again you get the hospital food
it's better than home food because it's
like different flavors and [ __ ]
and they have the best soups at
hospitals it smells hospitable
it does smell hospitally i don't like
the food as a patient
i like the food that they had in the
cafeteria that they would sell
but you could also go there later nicer
huh later
cafeteria like when you get better and
stuff you can go there when you're not
wearing your scrubs i mean the garment
with the booty in the back you know
yeah all right so this story is about
a chinese man in china and his parents
who uh went to a hospital together
and back in 2014 and uh
he had symptoms he was nauseous he was
vomiting and had an unsteady gait
what is that his butthole was ultimately
his walk unsteady
because walk is like oh yeah you're
right yeah a person's manner of walking
yeah
how did you know that
oh i thought it was g-a-t g-a-i-t
oh yeah g-a-t-e is gate that's what i
was thinking i didn't know there was
another gate oh he's not gonna have a
shitty gate
i thought you said gate like g-a-t-e but
she was throwing up and his mailbox
wasn't working
oh [ __ ] i thought it was the stomach
thing isn't there one that sounds like
that
grout gout gown god's not stomach no
it's joints
yeah what the [ __ ] we don't know [ __ ]
and grouts between the tiles
i thought growl was the guy from [ __ ]
the space
[Music]
[Applause]
speak for yourselves dumbasses you
spelled gate without the e [ __ ]
i said g-a-t-e you didn't say the e the
first time or at least i didn't hear it
you combined it together anyways this
story is about a guy named tian
and uh he was supposed to spend a few
days uh for a medical procedure at the
hospital
for whatever symptoms he was having and
following the procedure and when he was
presented with the medical bill he
decided to
dispute it saying that um
hmm nice i like the balls on this guy
yeah very very ballsy he said that he
wasn't administered
the appropriate treatment and he refused
to leave now i don't know how things are
done
in china because this isn't china
beijing specifically we speak on how
things are done
yeah how are these things i gotta keep
listening to the story
i don't know how things are done but i
feel like anything is possible
he refused to leave and
he had he ended up staying at this
hospital for a guess how many
how much how long you're about to say
years off oh [ __ ] i think about six
years
oh [ __ ] years six years
what what he didn't have to pay he
didn't
okay so check it okay so like you said
anything
maybe he only has to pay when he leaves
so he's like if i never leave i'll never
pay that probably is the logic here so
he's
he claims that he was administered the
wrong treatment
for the initial whatever they did he
wasn't healthy
uh yeah because he came in with symptoms
he did have symptoms they treated him
and then he says i'm not paying that
because you didn't treat me
properly so for him i don't know how
that even works out
like that logic works out and i don't
know how the hospital was like oh yeah
you're right we didn't treat you
properly
you get to stay here i guess and he
ended up staying there for six years
and during the course of the six years
this hospital did
take legal action against uh tian and
his parents because parents actually
moved in with them into the hospital
they moved in personal belongings
they spent chinese new year's at this
hospital like they actually made
a home out of this it's six [ __ ]
years so then
did he get a haircut in the six years
did he ever leave the room
i know i i don't know how effie did
leave or not
did he call it locksmith and now he has
his own [ __ ] key that would be
amazing he just locks out everyone else
like the like hospital staff terminal
but hospital that's what i was thinking
but yeah so um so over the course of
these years
uh there the hospital did try to kick
him out
um not hard enough [ __ ] six years
so hospital hospital took the family to
court on several occasions in 2019
uh after court ruling they were they
were even forced to waive the demands
for 1.26 million
yuan which is 195 000 in medical costs
meaning
the hospital wasn't couldn't charge uh
them for the medical costs and they
waived off the entire fee
amazing i don't know why yeah i don't
know how this even happens
okay so then they provided proof that
tian needed uh didn't need any medical
attention
and could be discharged arguing that he
was occupying hospital resources that
could be used to treat
real patients um and then uh just last
year 10
counters through the hospital alleging
medical negligence
and they continued to stay there for
another year
oh my god i don't like there's so much
like fine print now i'm like
what the [ __ ] going on here so this is
six plus years because they haven't left
yet
no just last week the judge in beijing
finally ruled that tien and his parents
were to finally leave the hospital award
and uh and
ruled that they were squatting there for
the past six years uh
but they were also entitled to
compensation from the hospital
no okay that's the energy i'm trying to
live in for [ __ ] 2021.
like that kind of audacity damn this is
some 2021
either like this guy's the king of
loopholes or he really has a legitimate
case
and then they [ __ ] them over well
apparently if he's getting awarded
compensation like what what happened
having your parents move in and stuff
that sounds kind of crazy
they don't really tell you like the
finer details yeah what kind of
issues did he have that wasn't solved i
don't know
because i'm assuming so nausea and and
vomiting and
open gate open gate
i'm steady gate so he's walking funny he
was nauseous
and he was throwing up so no one
identified what that was
because the only reason why i would stay
is like i'm still not better
and i need help right so that's what i
was saying i'm like so he's claiming
he's not healthy then like he's
he's not yeah oh the walk like the walk
is an easy thing to cheat you just like
yeah i'm not walking right damn you're
just walking they could be cons right
the whole family's just like let's get a
freebie it does sound like it but
also if the hospital's
negligent or they're not like on point
they might just be like oh we banished
them up get the [ __ ] out of here we want
to turn
more numbers yeah yeah and they feel
like hey my services weren't [ __ ]
completed
like you need to fix this yeah so and
then six years later
because i would just go to a different
hospital i wouldn't be like [ __ ] you
guys you guys don't do your work right
but what if there's no other hospital in
the area oh true
this is beijing though beijing is true a
[ __ ] major city
i know do you have any pictures of this
because i imagine there are like
pictures like
you know in a hospital room right it's
pretty clean
but after six years you're moving your
[ __ ] in there it's like a door like the
amount of stuff that's probably up i
want to be hung up like posters and
pictures and [ __ ]
the clothes line you know yeah and they
were all living together that's so
weird apparently the day that they were
forced to move out
is that the cops uh yeah like
authorities or whatever and they blurt
out someone's face
or something like that yeah it doesn't
look but check it there's a
another photo this is another angle
that's what had a burberry blanket
man you saw that [ __ ] is it a burberry
oh this one right here
go back go back watch this a burberry
blanket dude that one's balling
this is where his legs are shuffles i
think his legs are right here his feet
are not coming
i don't know but yeah but then the last
photo i have for you guys
bam commander well that's luggage
stuff i think this is their stuff oh
[ __ ] so that's
earlier they already packed up their
[ __ ] yeah they think this is someone
like it seems like they're
it's on a dolly and they're like
dragging it out now whatever this is
someone else did they get compensated
how much did they get compensated
i don't know what ground so it's it's a
this is a big question mark for me too
but family accepted 480 000 yawn which
is
73 000 in american dollars
and they agreed to finally move out of
the ward they had no rent
and check it when they left they had the
hospital ambulance taken home too
wow back to their actual home what the
[ __ ] happened
and why did the hospital okay at all
like because if you're in
okay if you're if you're a patient right
you get
you get serviced like it's like oh you
know nurse come help me whatever
so at what point were they just like man
just
leave them alone we're not going to help
them do [ __ ] well it sounds like
everything was tied up in litigation for
so long right so
after like i assume when he went to
court they were like [ __ ] we can't do
anything about
it now until it's over and it sounds
like it was stuck in court for years
maybe
yeah it sounds like it yeah it sounds
like it's like
whatever we got to do get the [ __ ] out
let's go let's give them the like
ambulance service
money okay pay them get out of here yeah
but how do you get ambulance to take you
home
that's crazy that's important
in china it's uh is it socialized
medicine
i don't know i'm assuming i don't know
because it's communist
yeah you would imagine everything is
right yeah but then my friend
was telling well he was teaching english
there and he was telling me that it's
not all free like the
cost of education and all that you still
got to pay and all that and i was like
what is that that's supposed to be
communist is that only for the good
education you know what i mean because
now you're getting private tutors and
stuff like that
well he wasn't at a private school he
was at a public university teaching
english
so like i always say like china's not
exactly communist
because they have a capitalist like
structure like how their economy economy
works i'm not sure about their
healthcare
but it's just so yeah it's weird i'm not
i'm not i'm not quite sure how to
classify them i mean the idea of
communism is
like unreachable right the communist
party and communism are two different
things
like actual pure communism there's like
no government yeah i don't know
i don't know what you just said that was
the biggest [ __ ] government ever
so yeah so i don't know this story
happened it
i honestly sounded like fake news like i
was like this is like some made-up [ __ ]
but
i i went through multiple sources and we
have it linked in the in the
that's an interesting story it happened
so i don't know damn
weird [ __ ] that is like
the best coupon ever right and you got
paid free
wow that's 73 grand i feel like there's
like extreme couponers looking at this
and they're like oh my god he got the
deal
he didn't even have to pay but do
couponers get money out of it too
yeah couponing you get free product
and then sometimes you even get paid oh
[ __ ] from you get money back
i like the rebates and stuff yeah can't
even get an ambulance into the hospital
here let alone to go home
[Music]
you